oh I got this right she's cool okay um I
got a friend over Oh sweetie that's so
nice hi I'm Mary Oh Oh do ba ba ba uh
bill Kevin is your friend okay okay this
is gonna sound so crazy but you gotta
believe me okay
trust me Samantha she was created
through my video game The Sims I don't
know what I'm supposed to do should we
call the cops no no no no mom you can't
do that Wow oh great
actually I have a lot of space and I
love to entertain I really love it all
right well let's get going get you some
towels okay come on once you pick up
your shoes don't leave your shoes around
the house see now just bum y'all
oh this is
hey now this is my daughter students
from Wow ah wah wah wah she went off to
college so I guess it's like you're my
new daughter now I love this
pretty much by 100 and here's the towel
for you and you want to take a shower
because ah very smelly ha ha oh we
remember - ha ha mmm don't go to Paris
ok I like your little spins I took dance
and I had to quit Oh allergy
Oh
I love you hey guys thanks for watching
episode 3 of Semites world I hope you
have fun I really like Mary the mom I
just love creepy characters you know
that I do not have a sneak peek for
episode 4 just yet because I am filming
it this Saturday
it should be fun though because John the
dad comes home from work to have dinner
with his family and meet Samantha who
they apparently adopted let's just say
he doesn't like her I will see you next
Friday for episode 4 Asim meets world
thank you guys so much for watching
subscribe to my channel I love you bye